para distinguir entre el sonido de un
bombo de algo que tiene una frecuencia
mucho más alta como es un vídeo de las
alas de una abeja al volar el cerebro
usa la cóclea para diferenciar entre
estos dos tipos diferentes de sonidos la
diferencia entre un bombo y el zumbido
de una abeja es la frecuencia el bombo
tiene una frecuencia muy baja mientras
que las alas de una abeja al moverse tan
rápido en el aire producen un zumbido
con una frecuencia más alta la
información del sonido del bombo de baja
frecuencia y de las alas de una abeja de
alta frecuencia llega al oído y
finalmente alcanza la cóclea ya
explicamos con detalle cómo la cóclea
convierte la onda sonora en impulsos
nerviosos que después llegan al cerebro
pero ahora veremos cómo la cóclea
distingue sonidos que tienen frecuencias
diferentes y cómo se mantiene esta
diferencia todo el camino hasta el
cerebro de manera que pueda distinguir
estos sonidos esto se conoce como
procesamiento auditivo el cerebro
necesita diferenciar sonidos de
distintas frecuencias pueden
escuchar sonidos con frecuencias desde
los 20 hearts hasta los 20000 hertz este
es un rango muy grande y para poder
distinguir sonidos de baja y alta
frecuencia el cerebro usa la cóclea en
particular algo llamado afinación
vacilar y el término vacilar viene de la
membrana habacilar que está dentro de la
cóclea esta membrana contiene muchas
células vellosas y si desarrollamos esta
cóclea normalmente se encuentra en
espiral pero si la desarrollamos de
manera que quedara plana encontraríamos
varias células vellosas este extremo es
la base de la cóclea y este el ápex o
extremo final aquí está la base y el
ápex está aquí si lo desenrollar amos y
viéramos cuáles células se activan según
los diferentes sonidos nos daríamos
cuenta de que las células vellosas que
se encuentran en la base de la cóclea se
activan con sonidos de muy alta
frecuencia y que las células en el ápex
son estimuladas con sonidos de muy baja
frecuencia veamos otra imagen para
comprender mejor esto esta imagen
muestra a la cóclea desenrollada
esta es la base de la cóclea que indicó
con este color y este es el ápex de la
cóclea y encontramos células vellosas
por toda la membrana habacilar
esta es la membrana bacilar y está llena
de todo tipo de células vellosas las
células cercanas a la base responden a
sonidos de altas frecuencias
aquí tenemos 1600 hertz y las células
cercanas a la pex responden a sonidos de
bajas frecuencias aquí tenemos 25 hertz
aquí se detectan sonidos como el del
bombo y por acá se detectan sonidos como
el batir de las alas de una abeja
conforme los sonidos de frecuencias
diferentes llegan al oído estos van a
estimular diferentes partes de la
membrana habacilar si alguien toca un
bombo que tiene una frecuencia muy baja
el sonido llega al oído medio luego a la
cóclea y va a recorrer toda esta
membrana habacilar hasta llegar a la
célula vellosa que responde a su
frecuencia particular digamos que el
bombo produce un sonido de 100 hertz las
ondas sonoras harán que el fluido dentro
de la cóclea se mueva hasta que aquellas
células que sean sensibles a esta
frecuencia de 100 g
que están más o menos por acá se activen
estas células van a disparar un
potencial de acción esta señal
finalmente llegará al cerebro y va a ser
asignado a una región particular del
cerebro esto de aquí es el cerebro y si
levantamos esta parte del cerebro
encontraremos algo llamado corteza
auditiva primaria y esta corteza
auditiva primaria esta región azul de
acá es responsable de recibir la
información de la cóclea de hecho
podemos ver que está dividida de forma
similar a cómo está dividida la cóclea
según las distintas frecuencias la
corteza auditiva primaria también es
sensible a sonidos de frecuencias
diferentes por ejemplo esta parte de la
corteza recibe información de células
vellosas sensibles a frecuencias de 0.5
hertz y esta otra parte de la corteza
auditiva recibe información de las
células vellosas que son sensibles a
frecuencias de 16 hertz y la razón por
la que esto es importante es porque el
cerebro necesita distinguir sonidos
diferentes si todas las células vellosas
fueran sensible
es a todas las frecuencias sonoras al
escuchar cualquier sonido se activaría
en todas las células y enviarían una
enorme señal al cerebro y el cerebro no
podría distinguir sonidos diferentes por
lo que al tener esta afinación vacilar
el cerebro puede diferenciar entre
sonidos de alta frecuencia y sonidos de
baja frecuencia esta distribución de
baja frecuencia se conoce como mapa tono
tópico en resumen tenemos ondas sonoras
que llegan al oído diferentes sonidos
tienen frecuencias diferentes y
necesitamos poder distinguir entre ellas
las ondas sonoras entran y llegan a la
cóclea y ahí activan diferentes células
vellosas los sonidos de alta frecuencia
activan a las células que están cerca de
la base de la cóclea y si el sonido es
de baja frecuencia va a activar a las
células cerca de la ápex y estas células
vellosas van a enviar acciones que se
agruparán para formar el nervio auditivo
el nervio auditivo lleva axones de cada
una de estas células dentro de la cóclea
el nervio auditivo finalmente llega al
cerebro
en donde separa sus fibras que llegarán
a partes diferentes del cerebro